the 30th anniversary of Hoosiers a
reunion this weekend and David joining
us now David good to have you on the
program where are you right now
right now I'm in Ladoga Indiana where
wait skank who played oli lives and this
is the first time I've been back to
Indiana in 30 years so if I don't make
it to the reunion Dan send out a sheriff
I'm either in Wade's basement or I'm in
some cornfield somewhere can Ollie make
free throws now well we heard you we
were listening before I called in and I
can't lie all I can still probably make
some free throws does that underhand
technique down
how about Maris Jimmy Chitwood can he
still hit jumpers you know Maris had a
pure shot that's about you know he was
no D Maris he didn't like to play
defense very much but the guy was a pure
shooter I played ball with him when he
came out to LA to try and be an actor
and he could really stroke the ball he
had a great shot so I'm guessing he can
still shoot how did you get this role in
Hoosiers I was an actor and I had just
got an agent so I had been auditioning
for about six months and you know I just
went through the normal audition process
but I was the only kid that was not from
Indiana all the rest of the boys were
like local Indiana guys and they were
real basketball players I was not so I
kind of faked it a little bit when did
you find out Gene Hackman and Dennis
Hopper were going to be in the movie
were they already in the movie they're
uh you know I don't know you can ask
Wade that he might know better than I do
but pretty soon I mean I know that they
were talking about Burt Reynolds for a
bit and no you know yeah exactly I think
David Anspaugh said oh no the director
and it didn't work out so Jean was great
to work with uh and pretty soon you know
we found out or I found out that it was
gonna be Dennis Hopper and I was gonna
beat his son and Barbara Hershey who I
had kind of a giant crush on
we all did there David yeah yeah did
barber come back for the reunion
she is probably not going to come back
I'm not sure she was a happiest camper
on that movie but why no because she I
think she thought the movie was going to
be about her and it turned out so maybe
she wasn't the happiest on that movie
but you know I still had a crush on her
she's a great actress but it probably
wasn't the best experience for how
intimidate who was more intimidating
Dennis Hopper Gene Hackman
Oh Jean by far I mean Dennis hung out
with us you know I can't tell you
everything in Indiana give me a little
bit I mean Dennis Hopper rest in peace
but you know we got after a little bit
with Dennis and you know Jean was very
intimidating he's not like a chatty dude
you know you're not gonna go up and chat
with him he's all business and I mean I
was definitely intimidated the first
scene I think I did with him was in the
classroom and I could barely look up you
know you're sitting there acting with
Popeye Doyle I was a little little rough
how tough was it to learn to play 50s
style basketball well for me because I
wasn't really a player I mean for me it
was easy you know because I just play I
mean my playing style was actually like
modeled after Kurt Rambis not a lot of
skill but a lot of heart desire I was
probably the worst player of all the
boys but you know I just played very
sort of basic and fundamental some of
the other guys you know that had a more
sort of modern style had to adjust a
little bit but I think that everybody
did pretty well he's David Knight or who
plays Everett in Hoosiers he was also in
platoon and Bull Durham what did you
think when that movie first came out you
know I don't think any of us expected it
to be very popular
you know I saw it at a screening in Los
Angeles because I was in platoon and it
was the same production company hemdale
and at the screening you know I happen
to be seated right behind James Woods
and he was not digging it he was a
little bit bored so
I was like oh this isn't gonna work so I
was sent a caught off guard to be honest
with you I thought it was a good movie
but it was my first movie so I was
definitely going to like it
but you know I was a little bit caught
off guard by the popularity I think we
all were what did you think a bull
durham bull durham was a lot of fun i
mean we I was hanging out you know most
of the guys on the team are the extras
that played on the other teams I didn't
have that much doing that movie so I was
hanging out with them and they were all
minor league ball players you know I
shanked like was there a baseball player
major leaguer named Donnie Edwards you
know there was member I think there was
a football player Donnie Edwards played
you see I might be getting yeah I might
be getting the names wrong but you know
I was hanging out with be alive guys
that were spiring to be in the majors
and it was that was a lot of fun I had a
lot of fun I hung out with Tim Tim
Robbins and Kevin was Kevin Costner was
exceedingly nice and kind of one of the
only movie stars that I ever worked with
that would pay attention when other
actors were working and he watched me do
one of my scenes and gave me some really
good notes so I had a lot of fun on that
movie and I played basketball with the
director at the why Hollywood why ron
shelton yeah and all those guys from
white men can't jump
and one other thing down we were
listening to your show and tell that
dude who called and said this slap shot
is one of the worst for solutions on
crack
iMovie was great David conduct is wade
is wade there yeah wade way to sit right
okay let that a wage shank who played
ali in Hoosiers so from Everett to Ollie
and Wade joins us now how often do get
asked to shoot free throws Wade do you
really shoot him like that and I'll tell
you what when I was when I did the movie
I was in high school at the time I
played for my high school team and my
coach probably wished I would have kept
shooting them underhanded mad beauty
knives beholder
who is the worst player on the Hoosier
team according to the script or
according to the players Wade I plead
the fifth on that one is it was David
the worst player was David the worst
player fundamentally yeah yeah as far as
you know like he said he's Kurt Rambis
you know not very not very good score
but he did all the dirty dirty work you
know and you had a big scene dramatic
scene with the free-throws how many
takes did it take for you to get that
round how many times I had twice - that
was it shot some different angles and
whatnot and believe it or not under here
fries aren't that hard to hit you know
it's just you know a lot of people shot
him back in the day you had Rick very
shot on Wilt Chamberlain tried at one
time of course you tried everything and
I'm surprised shocked didn't try once or
twice but it wasn't that difficult to do
the hardest thing made to do was dribble
off my foot any other time q you name
but I'll tell you what you try to do it
it ended up bouncing off my knee and
they said we're checking that we're
tired tired and you're gonna screen the
movie tonight it's at what the festivity
in the movie tonight and six eight and
the high school of the high school gym
that we played and yes if I told you
thirty years ago you'd be famous for
that role what would you say to me and
the only reason I tried as I got a day
out of school to come up trying
Indianapolis to ourselves and there was
like 1500 kids in two day tryout and ice
when I heard to have a good time at the
time they were building the the high
school Hall of Fame Museum and Newcastle
where Steve Alford played and I thought
that's what this is going to be about
which is just gonna be a local base I
really didn't know gene hat gosh I mean
he did Popeye Doyle back in the
seventies there's a tease and he hadn't
been seen for a long time and sure
didn't know who Dennis Hopper was in
fact you asked who was up for that part
Jack Nicholson was actually after that
part the Gene Hackman took and the only
he didn't take it was cause the to
Jake's because he was contracted to do
the to Jake's
and David asked fall and and I'm sorry
an Angelo pizza went to him said what
who would you say and he pointed out
gene Hamming stays perfect for it that's
how he got the job
Wow yeah imagine that he wanted to do it
bad did you imagine him being the coach
of Hickory team huh and did a chopper
images offer really that would be a
party time for you guys wait fun this
weekend tell the boys tell Maris we set
a low and congratulations
wait skank and David nye Dorf in
Hoosiers thirty years later the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience